[Music]
hello and welcome I'm Nancy Salzman
I'm the president of Nexium Corporation
and executive success programs
what would happen if each of my secrets
came out arrested today Nancy Salzman as
well as her daughter Lauren Salzman the
upside of letting go of your secrets is
that you will have a lot more freedom
Nancy Sal's been pleading Dylan solzman
now pleading guilty Allison Mack cracks
the downside of your secrets coming out
is punishment
my whole company was destroyed
and my whole life fell apart
do you think the person who's being
branded should be completely nude and
sort of held to the table like a sort of
almost like a sacrifice
[Music]
the explosive trial of
[Music]
brainwashing sex abuse and even branding
is really the psychological torture of
women for decades
if he gets off then it's back to just
full blend Battle Stations and then
they're coming after us
Keith I can rationalize that he's crazy
but Nancy
she puzzles me more than Keith
seventeen thousand people got good
results
where are they
people think anyone who's still around
just brainwashed [ __ ] of Keith
how insulting
how could I have allowed myself to be
there
these are adult women making decisions
back off
she's young and she's alone and he wants
her to be a Slave
the woman allegedly kept confined to a
room is expected to be on the stand
today
what the
going into this I thought cave was
innocent
I was wrong
I wonder if she's really waking up or
just trying to save herself